[Music]
people whose homes are sinking in this
Las Vegas neighborhood North Las Vegas
neighborhood I should say could get help
soon a bill would give 30 million
dollars to help 90 families in Windsor
Park to help them move now the
neighborhood is near MLK and Kerry and
it's actually built on a fault line
that's shifting and that is causing all
these homes to crack and then sink into
the ground Senate Bill 450 would
relocate families dealing with this 20
million dollars would come from the city
and then the state would put up the 10
million dollars the area would then
become a park the bill passing its first
committee now heading to the full Senate